[Applause]
in all seriousness with the chad mc
chadwick bozeman yeah situation
i will i had to step into studio 2 the
other day
and [ __ ] weep a little bit but it was
so sad
while we were at work while we were here
work you were in here uh
research napping or whatever you do yeah
robbie was out there and then what did
you do i went to studio two and i
watched the last scene of
avengers you you know the not the last
scene but when they take out thanos when
all the guys go it's
a tear jerker the first person to come
back
to help cap is black panther
so he steps out of that little circle
that the chinese man made probably wuhan
[ __ ] virus right there
yeah stepped out
said something we got your back this at
the other and i was like oh no bro this
[ __ ] got me
it's too sad man it was sad and it's so
[ __ ] sad i've been thinking about why
it's so profoundly sad yeah i can't
figure it's like
kobe level sadness you know what i think
it is
i think it is that
one it was unbelievably shocking like we
had no clue yeah in the same way with
kobe right it seemed like someone who
was invincible
and all of a sudden yeah gone but
the age is so close in proximity to ours
that we felt our mortality a little bit
at least for me i was like 43 it started
four years ago
that means he already had it prior to
four years when they found out
bro he's probably filmed [ __ ] the
black panther with that [ __ ]
2016 that movie came out 2018. man damn
sure while he's doing press and
everything he knows
we saw him at the all-star game in 2018
or 2019 whatever
right yeah yeah got this huge ovation
because you know they're like showing
the stars
and black panther had just come out he
got the biggest ovation by far
he just seemed like he didn't seem like
phony or whatever he just seemed like
humbly smiling or whatever and it was
just like oh he seems like a decent dude
that's
i'm just whatever but like bruh
something about it just i should god
we had no idea i think that's the thing
he hid it for so long
i think he was just starting to enjoy
like
peak fame where like he's a superstar in
the making but he also actually really
seems like
to care about acting and about the art
and the way that i don't think most of
them do
right something about it man i think all
of it added together plus what he meant
for black people like black panther
meant so much
bro how many times do you see it three
times i just
i just [ __ ] yeah that's not even that
many real talk that's
very white if you'd only see it three
times yeah man it was just something man
i i was like
colon cancer that i have in my family
and i'm 36 he's
got diagnosed at 39. he got diagnosed at
39.
that means he probably had it at 38.
that means i'm
a year and a half yeah away from when he
had it
yeah i think that [ __ ] hit me like oh my
god bro
like i think another thing happened in
corona times where it's like oh you just
died from corona
or police brutality yeah those are the
only deaths that happened
and then we saw this other death that
would be normal-ish
pre-corona yeah but now seems so out of
the blue
yeah she's like oh yeah yeah dude you're
just out
when you start learning about a lot of
the things that he did like he would go
to
children's hospitals that were actually
dying from cancer as well
as he's dying from cancer